aujourd'hui pour la moindre petite
occasion le moindre petit dîner entre
potes on monte un gros WhatsApp comme si
on a les gérer un truc de fou tu montes
un gros ok tu crées un gros what's up
c'est bon on va dîner ok tu averti ma
team d'accord tu mets Rémi dans le
groupe c'est parti ok je peux plus je
sors des gros j'en ai marre je veux plus
être non mais gros
en plus c'est chaud ça se voit quand tu
sors d'un groupe hein c'est écrit en
grand et cramé genre regarde le groupe
il y en a je peux plus les amis le
groupe a simple plus insupportable pour
moi c'est celui des parents d'élèves non
pas la famille je le connais famille tu
la famille family hein
vous l'avez family
on l'a amené en anglais
non le groupe WhatsApp qui me dérange
vraiment les amis c'est celui des
parents d'élèves je peux plus
qui sont ces gens sur investi dans la
scolarité de leurs enfants
ils ont pas de vie ces gens c'est
spécial je
le tour à 23h15 carrément gros WhatsApp
du CE2
maman Bérénice écrit
alerte poésie
ah merde poésie bordel alerte attentat
oui ça m'inquiète Alerte Enlèvement je
suis soucieux même Alerte à Malibu ça
m'amuse mais